[Musique]
stéphanie grammond michel suau j'ai luc
ferrandez bonsoir
non encore une fois aujourd'hui et les
gens qui ont vu ça sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les bulletins télévisés un
hôpital qui a été visé en tout cas pas
été visée qui a été touchée un hôpital
pour enfants mario paul 300000 personnes
pas mal encerclé qui arrivent pas sortir
pas d'eau pas d'électricité dans
certains quartiers bon bref on regarde
ça et quoi dire d'autre que de se dire
c'est fanny je commence avec vous que
nous sommes totalement impuissant devant
ça
on est dans une situation qui est
extrêmement d'echirolles parce que on
regarde ces bombardements lors on
regarde l'horreur on regarde les enfants
les femmes les gens qui combattent qui
essaient de fruits et on ne peut pas
rester indifférent et en même temps au
marche sur un fil de fer parce que oui
on entend les appels du l'ukraine qui
souhaiteraient que le temps
interviennent et faire merci à la nier
mais d'un autre côté on voit la réaction
de le temps et on comprend parce que si
on faisait ça ça reviendrait à dire que
on devrait à mettre des avions un russe
et qui ne respecteraient pas cette 7,7
contre un état et donc on risque de se
retrouver dans une troisième guerre
mondiale
avec une arme nucléaire est un despote
comme monsieur poutine qui est on n'est
pas trop sur ce il poserait pas sur le
bouton donc oui c'est catastrophique ce
qu'on voit en ce moment en ukraine mais
on veut pas non plus prendre réagir à
tout ça et prendre des décisions qui
nous mènerait à des conséquences encore
plus graves
l'udc sur la même question sur
l'impuissance finalement partir du
moment où on connaît les implications
d'une implication militaire éventuelle
de l'otan
ouf dramatique et aussi terrible que
soient les scènes de guerre que nous
voyons elles sont moins payeurs que
l'utilisation d'une arme nucléaire
contre l'ukraine si par exemple ça a été
évoqué il parait t'il parce que ça des
rumeurs ça est évoquée par rue un
poutine avec son état major la
prostituée utilisé une arme ce tract il
est à dire de courte portée contre une
ville de l'ukraine servir au groupe
extrait rasé première chose la deuxième
chose c'est pas vrai que l'occident
l'otan est absent absente de ce conflit
les stingers qui descend qui sont les
hommes qui permettent d'attaquer les
avions étaient fournis par l'allemagne
les javelin qui sont les armes qui
permet d'attaquer des tanks ont été
fournies par les états unis les drones
sont fournies par la turquie le canada
fournit des cartes extrêmement
détaillées qui permet d'identifier à un
tank prêts ou les ressorts l'otan est
vraiment impliqué dans cette guerre
michel
deux choses d'abord une zone d'exclusion
aérienne c'est un non poli pour
commencer une bière alors si on fait ça
on s'en va vers une guerre c'est
inévitable c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
le faire malheureusement
d'autre part on sait que lorsque c'est
aïda tchétchénie est arrivé ailleurs car
les russes ne vois pas ce qu'ils aiment
sur le terrain ils deviennent de plus en
plus brutaux si on visait un hôpital
pour enfants ou pas je ne sais pas je
peux pas vous le dire mais c'est clair
que la situation ne porte pas bien
militairement pour les russes devaient
ils vont gagner 103 jours cette histoire
là ils sont en train de s'enliser et
qu'est ce qui est arrivé dans tous les
autres conflits régionaux dans lesquels
des russes se sont embarqués au cours
des années poutine ils sont devenus
extrêmement violent et dans certains cas
la limite de la barbarie tiré sur un
hôpital pour enfants c'est exactement ça
c'est de la barbarie on va y revenir
évidemment on vient chez nous demain se
fait huit fois qu'on en parle mais là
demain ça y est jean charest se va
officialiser sa course à la chefferie
pour le parti conservateur je vous
montre un élément quand même nouveau
c'est à bacchus sondages d'opinion il ya
deux volets je vous montre le premier
chez les canadiens
mais ce cher opinion positive
négative neutre ne sais pas jean charest
pierre polie et monsieur madame lewis
charest monsieur paul yav égalité chez
tous les canadiens c'est bon mais chez
les conservateurs
monsieur paul yèvre qui elle vraiment
une longueur d'avancé on le voit sur ce
sondage là
demain la vraie dynamique va commencer
michels et je commence avec vous la
vraie dynamique va commencer bien malin
celui qui pourrait prédire malgré tout
comment ça va finir
actu du moulin et ils ne sont à ce qu'on
voit chez les conservateurs c'est des
électeurs conservateurs c'est pas les
membres du parti conservateur qui sont
encore plus à droite des électeurs ont
boudé l'oublier donc la france de
monsieur loyal et probablement plus
grande que ce qu'est ce que ça dit que
dans la situation actuelle parce qu'on
sait que ce congrès lors va devenir un
concours de bande de cartes de membres
et c'est là qu'il faut regarder où il
peut vendre ses cartes de malachie
paiement il ya un autre données de ce
sondage no qui est extrêmement troublant
charest c'est qu'au québec il ya 47 pour
ça des gens qui ont une opinion
défavorable de monsieur charest comment
voulez vous alors qu' il est évident axe
au québec qui a les ventes de plus de
carte de membre ou essayer de barres de
plus de 42 langues c'est difficile de
convaincre quelqu'un devenir membre du
parti conservateur pour beauté pour
jallet cathy dit non mais j'ai pas de
bonnes opinions tout le long alors ça
c'est un des choses auxquelles il va
devoir s'adresser c'est à dire toutes
les questions d'éthique est tous choqués
sur lesquels il pas parlé il ya 10
l'heure est au combat depuis dix ans et
on comprend pourquoi il était sous
enquête mais il va falloir qu'ils se
mettent à répondre à des questions parce
que sinon il va rester avec ce 47 août
les plus de jacques sont et qui se dit
une auto une bonne opinion du au québec
et ça ça pourrait le château stéphanie
weens et c'est effectivement c'est assez
frappant de voir ça quand on regarde la
répartition le régional comme comme le
disait michel au québec il n'a pas
d'appuis le en fait il ya 47 % des gens
qui ont une impression négative et il ya
seulement 20 % qui ont une opinion
positive de monsieur charest bons les
chiffres sont elles sont sont
intéressants et quand on compare avec
monsieur poignet ben lui seulement 8%
des gens au québec qui qui ont une
impression positive et 24% négative mais
les gens peut-être le connaissent un peu
moins ici qu'est ce que ça va donner
quand on apprendra à connaître davantage
il ya des méthodes qui peuvent être
assez des réparties assez en bottes
d'acier nature parce que ça plaira aux
gens ça reste à voir mais c'est vrai que
monsieur charest reste associé à les
gens attendent encore les casseroles
raisonnée du printemps attendent encore
les témoignages la commission
charbonneau alors c'est c'est pas
disparu comment votre su le faire pour
se renouveler et faire oublier cet
aspect là au québec cha c'est une très
belle c'est un grand défi 10 ans l'udc
sans réinventer parce que c'est un mot
un peu cliché l'âme il doit un peu se
redéfinir en tout cas chargé à une
partie de son image au québec donc ah
oui et puis ça va être très difficile je
pense que comme une erreur majeure a dit
ça je ne suis pas coupable point final
parce que la loi a décidé parce que j'ai
respecté la loi oui mais le financement
libéral dans cette année là était marqué
par le signe des spectateurs un
financement sectoriel poussé au au plus
loin que ça n'avait jamais été poussé
monsieur charest faisait la tournée des
bureaux qui est déjà qu'ils avaient
obtenu des contrats avec l'état ou qui
étaient susceptibles d'en avoir lui
personnellement faisait la tournée des
bureaux pour leur serrer la main c'était
pas illégal on n'a jamais fait la preuve
que parce qu'il a serré la main la
personne a eu un contre on n'a pas cette
preuve les essais déterminer maintenant
le comble le procès terminé pas le
procès aura jamais lieu donc il n'est
pas illégal mais est ce qu'il aurait pu
dire c'était une époque que je renie est
ce qu'il aurait pu dire je ne suis un
nouvel homme par rapport à ça je
reconnais mes méthodes électorale à
voiron ne reprendrait plus très bien et
ça va vous intéresser le prochain sujet
vous 3 vous écrivez là dessus une chaîne
vous écrivez beaucoup là-dessus le que
vous en parlait beaucoup aux stéphanie
c'est dans votre ville montreal le rem
de l'est
redessinée avec des améliorations qu'on
présente aujourd'hui qu'on a
expliqué hier aux journalistes qu on
présente aujourd'hui alors tourner quand
même assez rapide globalement est-ce
qu'il ya du jeu je cherche le positif
michel il y at il du progrès une chaîne
c'est
ça va être plus beau à terre on va faire
beaucoup de choses avec grelots des
bouts de seins mais c'est comme si
patrice je vous montrais lui les décès
des rénovations que je veux faire chez
moi et incidemment patrice je vais vous
envoyer la facture parce que ces
techniques ultra much va donner ça à la
ville de montréal quant au rêve lui même
il ya un peu près rien qui change on
pourra essayer de faire plus joli que le
rêve de l'ouest qui a carrément
stalinienne
ambassades arrondir les angles mais les
connexions avec le métro toutes ces
choses là il n'y a rien qui change
bon moi je pense quand même qu'ils ont
fait un effort extraordinaire dans le
design d'abord il faut comprendre que il
ne resterait que trois voies de
circulation sur rené lévesque s'est
quand même parier comme comme
proposition ensuite cette avance a bougé
un champ un beau ça vous enchante oui
bien sûr ça m'enchante mais mais mais il
reste qu'il faut voir comment ça va
fonctionner d'accord oui ça m'enchante
s'éteint c'est un geste ambitieux est un
geste très en dessous par contre on ne
fait pas une place publique mais pour
tous parce que là on va faire un place
publique sous le rêve
les places publiques ne fonctionnent pas
ou qu'on l'ait m il faut qu'il y ait
place occupée par exemple sur la
longueur le nom de rené lévesque des
poids certain que ça soit un succès mais
mettons ça de côté moi ce que j'aimerais
voir c'est avoir des garanties de la
caisse premièrement il ya la caisse a
dit que les piliers devait être coulé
sur place en les piliers qu'on voit sur
les images ce sont des coûts des piliers
en préférant prefab donc embêté europe
et précontrainte première chose deuxième
chose il ya des murs de quatre mètres
sur le tablier ceux des murs antibruit
de 4 mètres sur la table ils
apparaissent comme s'il avait deux
mètres sur l'image troisième chose la
largeur du tablier on aimerait vraiment
avoir les vraies données sur la largeur
du tablier parce que l'eau sur une image
on voit un cycliste en dessous du
tablier il ya pratiquement la même
largeur que le top 10 voyons donc c'est
quoi la vraie l'argent
vous êtes gaza les publicités on a
jolivet un peu aveugle mais voilà voilà
alors merci pour l'info
bon ok stéphanie oui c'est vrai que les
illustrations sont tout à fait charmante
on voit des enfants qui jouent dans les
herbes et puis y ait des des gens qui
lisent paisiblement leur journal mais ça
reste à voir si on peut créer vraiment
une rue piétonnière ou une place sur le
boulevard rené lévesque le quai pas
nécessairement le premier endroit où on
irait
se balader pendant ce sur tout ce qui
nous passe au dessus de la tête mais moi
je dirais surtout dans tout ce projet là
on parle de l'aspect urbanistique de
l'aspect architectural mais c'est comme
si on avait pris tout le projet à
l'envers et imaginez quelqu'un qui est
chez lui puis ville décide d'agrandir sa
maison logiquement ce qui va faire s'il
veut se dire bon quel est mon budget
premièrement deuxièmement et ensuite je
vais aller voir un architecte mais je
lui ai demandé de me faire un plan et
troisièmement mais ensuite je vais aller
voir trois ou quatre soumissionnaires
des contractants qui vont faire qu'ils
vont faire une soumission mais là avec
les roms c'est comme si on n'était pas
assez exactement à l'envers on est allé
voir directement formateur l'as keynes
et la belle lui dit ça tombait je fais
des rêves et on a dit bon maintenant
mieux j'en prends 1 et puis et puis le
bain on se demande combien ça va coûter
et on ne sait toujours pas alors c'est
un stand rôle de processus on a mis la
charrue devant les boeufs et oui on a
tous de l'ambition pour le transport
collectif et oui on voudrait tous se
revitaliser certains certaines zones de
l'est de montréal ça fait pas de doute
mais sur le processus c'est un peu
difficile à suivre le pays il ya peu de
transparence encore maintenant oui
d'ailleurs le comité cohen qui a déposé
un rapport d'étape d'ici essentiel que
tous les joueurs soient consultés soit
autour de la table donc le sous-texte
deux soeurs envoyé à laquelle s'était
arrêté de penser que vous êtes seul à
décider de tout mais sur le dernier tour
de table sur la nécessité sur l'utilité
sur l'achalandage de la caisse est quand
même revenu que d'autres chiffres que la
rtm avait dit pas besoin
la ligne verte et c est ce que j'avais
est ce que vous êtes plus
optimiste face aux besoins de transport
pour reprendre l'expression galvaudée
structurants dans l'est michel
ce que je note c'est que le rêve ils
vont être en compétition avec le métro
au lieu d'être un complément planit et
au métro et ça c'est le gros problème
cette chose-là enlever la connexion à
d'horribles ne rien dire ne peut pas la
remettre ça va coûter trop cher
si c'est pas intégré au système actuel
de transport en commun et ça ne sera pas
parce que c'est pas dans l'intérêt
financier de la caisse qui veut garder
ses passagers plus longtemps possible
c'est pas de bol du bon stéphanie sur
cette question-là du du besoin quand
même ouais il ya quand même un grand
nombre de passagers du futur rémy qui
vont et qui sont des passagers actuels
des modes de transport collectifs qui
existe déjà donc est ce que est ce que
ça vous est ce que ça en vaut le coup et
c'est sûr mais aucun projet de transport
en commun qui est rentable mais il faut
quand même qu'on soit capable de dire ok
est ce qu'on a le meilleur projet et
avantages qu est-ce qui est ce qu'on a
la meilleure formule moi je suis pas
nécessairement convaincu de ça c'est sûr
quand on peut retourner la table de
dessin
ben oui on sait ce que je vais vous dire
ce qu'on veut c'est ce qu'on veut éviter
évidemment mais en même temps si on va
trop vite le problème c'est qu'à la fin
pour fort longtemps que les conclusions
là tu le
laisses doit être décontaminé des
espèces en partie des états
industrialisés on doit construire du
résidentiel on doit passer du transport
en commun ya tout un grand projet de
redéveloppement des liasses partir ce
projet là en disant on va organiser le
projet autour du rem parce que le réal
mais la solution choisie par la caisse
comme le disent et stéphanie on prend
pas le projet par le bon bout ceci étant
dit est ce que ça va nous reporter de 10
ans mais peut-être que savons-nous
reporter disent ah mais ça c'est très
triste mais ça serait mieux que de faire
le projet à l'envers ok donc vous vous
matériel et fresnes où traînent vous 3
matériel et fresnes
malheureusement vont faire ceux
actuellement parce qu'il est mal parti
quel est il est partie strictement pour
les intérêts de la caisse
je reçois le charbo le grand patron au
18h30 ce soir je posais des questions
vous soulevez entre autres merci
beaucoup à vous trois bonnes soirées au
revoir bonsoir merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit